And in this exercise, I'm giving you I'm
Gonna Give You hints.
along the way
this exercise is going to give us a problem.
And it will ask us to provide both.
the pmf
also known as a probability distribution and the CDF.
For this particular problem. Let's see what it says.
So here in this example we get to
Look at random variable. Pmf and CDF. Let
X be the number of patients who visit a
specialized Clinic during offers hours on some
particular day.
So again when you when you see an uppercase letter.
in statistics and probability of theory they're talking about
a random variable
So this random variable trying to
think of a table?
This table contains the number of patients who visit.
a clinic during office hours one Patient to
Patient three patients on
for this random variable X. The only possible values are 0
1 2 3 and 4.
That means you can have up to four patients visiting that clinic it
won't be.
And more than that.
So if you look at the table of the random variable, you would have
zero one two, three and four.
With probabilities point three point 25 Point
20 point 50. So for example, what is the probability that
zero patients show up?
point three point
Point 30 like 30% chance no one who shows up and what is
the probability that for patients show up Point 15?
Oh like 15%
now
the question asks
What is P4?
what is the probability of
The fourth value of the random variable by the way, I mean the mistake.
50% is for three not four we
have to find out for
so basically we have a table.
two columns
column one has
five values zero one two, three and four like the number
of patients you can have
Column two however has four.
the last one
Like the probability for when the I have
four patients, that's something you have the calculate.
So let's focus on question. Number one, we'll spend five minutes on
this problem 5 or 10 minutes on this problem.
Here's a hint for X problem. Number one.
Then the probability number the number probability.
Is somewhere between zero.
and one
for this one you don't have to do CDF or pmf.
Just figure out basic arithmetic.
Okay.
Here's another hint add them up.
First of all, add these up and see how what they add up to.
and remember that
probably can go all the way up to one.